sur le rôle de la banque centrale
européenne alors déjà elle a joué un
rôle important pour effectivement à
travers ses achats d'actifs réduire le
taux d'intérêt sur les emprunts publics
elle a très bien joué ce rôle
aujourd'hui les taux sont son nul voire
négatif la france emprunte à des taux
négatifs jusqu'à des périodes de 12 ans
jusqu'à des échéances de 12 ans qui est
considérable beaucoup de pays européens
sont son pareil maintenant est-ce
qu'elle pourrait aller plus loin oui
évidemment nous ce qu'on propose c'est
d'annuler les dettes publiques qui sont
bilan de la banque centrale c'est-à-dire
ses 2400 milliards d'euros que vous
évoquez tout à l'heure et c'est un
chiffre qui est en progression constante
parce que la banque centrale rachète de
plus en plus de dette publique sur les
marchés
et notre proposition c'est que la banque
centrale passe un contrat avec les états
en dix ans nous sommes aujourd'hui dans
une situation économique très difficile
nous possédons une quantité importante
de vos dettes
nous acceptons de l'annuler mais en
échange vous investissez massivement
pour sauver la situation économique et
pour relancer l'économie qui en a bien
besoin
c'est donc pour ça que la bce peut jouer
un rôle considérable dans la relance
économique
alors j'en termine par la henri
sterdyniak nous dit oui mais la bce si
elle fait ça elle aura un d un bilan
déséquilibré
j'ai envie de dire très bien et alors
qu'elle est qu'elle est la conséquence
de ça est ce qu'une banque centrale peut
faire faillite
bien sûr que non c'est même christine
lagarde elle-même qui l'a reconnu et qui
a dit récemment qu'une banque centrale
ne pouvait jamais être à court de
monnaie ça c'est quand même quelque
chose qu'il faut souligner donc la
question et j'y reviens c'est toujours
de savoir comment on utilise ce pouvoir
de création monétaire au profit de la
société et au profit de la relance
écologique
[Musique]